the house committee set up an  investigative setup to investigate  the january 6 insurrection is underway  committee chairman  benny thompson opened up the first  hearing of the select committee  investigating the january 6 assault on  the u.s capitol with a graphic video  of the attack four officers injured in  the attack testified today before the  committee  i could have lost my life that day  not once but many times we must know  what happened here at the capitol we  must also know  what happened every minute of that day  in the white house  every phone call every conversation  every meeting  leading up to during and after the  attack  the department of justice has ruled that  former trump officials can testify if  the committee calls them  as witnesses